Elizabeth is with us in Orlando Florida
hi Elizabeth how are you hi I am
fabulous how are you Dave better than I
deserve what's up yay
so I am completely debt free and I just
finished my emergency fund good for you
my boyfriend
thank you my boyfriend and I lived
together he is now on his debt snowball
and he purchased a condo before we knew
about your ways so we have discussed
marriage we're not engaged yet so now
I'm not sure what to do my thoughts are
either to save up virtually 20 percent
that would act as my down payment for a
house or if I should start investing RM
saving up and investing for retirement
during the 15 percent or save up a pile
of money so that when we do get married
I can either help him with the debt
snowball or put that money towards the
20 percent that will knock off the PMI
of our condo well for today there's not
an engagement correct and you don't pay
money on your roommate stuff exactly so
he's running his deal you're running
your deal and that means that today
you're on baby step 4
now if this changes you mean you're
putting 15% away for retirement if this
changes and there's a ring on your
finger that with a date certain then you
look over at his debts no Bongo that's
getting ready to be mine and I would
stop my baby step 4 and start piling up
a side fund to the day after we get home
from the honeymoon finish his dead
snowball okay but I wouldn't do that
until there's a reason to so even though
I said we're obviously hoping to get
married I shouldn't save my 20% in case
I would need my down payment until as
well if you know I would just say you
know the this thing's heading towards
marriage or it's heading towards a
breakup yes okay yes we're men toward
marriage the problem no but I'm just
saying you know in three years from
today you're going to be married or
you're going to be looking for a house
yes okay
so once we know which direction you're
going we all know what to stop the baby
step four and save for great we're going
to say for a house or we're going to
save for two knock out his debt snowball
after the honeymoon which is I think
where it's going and you do - mm-hmm
how long would you hit pause on baby
step four until the honeymoon I'm saying
like if we do get married and then we
start investing what should be the or I
start saving to knock off his debt
snowball or would you be able to save
enough to finishes that snowball between
now and the time you got married
possibly okay
well once you've got enough in your
account to pay his debts off after
marriage then you're just sitting there
waiting for the honeymoon to be over and
write checks then I'd go back to my baby
step four fabulous does that make sense
eight except for because what I'm going
to do is just jostle this back and forth
to where you're not paying money for
somebody stuff you're not married to
until you're married but as soon as
you're married I won't be able pull the
trigger and knock it out and then the
two of you both are in baby step four at
that point right yeah and that's where
you would be so that that's how we're
working it good stuff good stuff well I
hope it all works out for you kiddo
and I appreciate you calling in hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]